hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
within his unfinished work the posses
Blaise Pascal engages in a very
interesting set of reflections on what
tyranny consists in and he doesn't just
mean political tyranny where one person
or class dominates another he is also
thinking about tyranny spread throughout
the social fabric and within the realm
of relationships so we could speak of a
tyrannical marriage or a tyrannical
friendship neither one of which are
really going to be much of a marriage or
friendship if that's the case and the
same general principle can go all the
way up to the international level as
well so what does he tell us that
tyranny consists in he gives us two
things that really could be definitions
one is willing or it's also translated
as wanting the the French for it is var
the word that we use for two will
wanting to have in one way or one manner
une voix in french what can only be had
in another so demanding or desiring
imposing upon things that what is
appropriate in one area be the paradigm
or the map or the blueprint for all
other areas and we'll come back to
examples of that in a moment another
definition that he gives and it's
actually one of the subject headings in
the French although not in all the
English translations is desire and there
it's just translation of this year right
in French of universal domination
sometimes translated as universal power
domain accion Universelle beyond its
scope beyond it's in French or the
legitimate
or during the appropriateness that it
would have now notice that that Paschal
in this is not saying that nobody should
ever give anybody any commands that were
all being tyrannical by doing that he's
not saying power is a bad thing he's not
even suggesting that we need to change
society or social structures or
relationships in any sort of
revolutionary way what he is pointing
out is that there is a tendency to take
what we've got that's legitimate and
then go too far with it so if we look at
the examples that he has to illustrate
this right we go back to the willing to
have in one way what can only be had in
another way he says we render different
duties in French d'avoir the word for to
ought to write we have different duties
or different obligations to different
merits and when he speaks of merits
there we're talking about people who
have or express some sort of value they
they possess a quality and those
qualities in fact Paschal thinks do in
fact obligate or produce a should in
relation to them so he talks about the
strong we should in fact recognize that
some people are stronger than others in
many different ways physically stronger
you know with muscles or mentally
stronger stronger in terms of being able
to call upon greater resources whether
those be of wealth or of power or
prestige we could talk about all
different types of strength and there is
something that is strength and we render
something to it but we don't render
everything to it likewise attractiveness
here it's translated in the English as
the fair and he says in French de Bowl
right the the beautiful the people who
are
attractive either physically or in terms
of personality or perhaps even they they
just occupy a privileged place within
the fashion constellation of the time
right and there is something to be
rendered to them what else he brings up
the sensible the people who he calls de
bonus be the people who have a good mind
the people who can think things through
maybe sort through difficult financial
decisions or who have good advice to
give you about how to raise your
children or the person who fixes your
computer and it breaks down right he
also talks about the pious the people
who are in some way more connected with
the divine and through their practice
through their understanding a little bit
later he'll also talk about the learner
the savants the people who have studied
the people who have mastered some sort
of discipline and can tell you about it
now each of them has their own
legitimate scope each of them does have
things that we ought to render to them
so he says we render different duties to
different merits the duty of love to the
pleasant to the agri-yob
the people who we enjoy we thought he
thanks to love those who are actually
pleasant the duty of fear to the strong
we should respect those who actually do
have power that doesn't mean that we say
everything that they do is a ok but you
know if we see the police person and he
or she has a gun in a baton and taser
and pepper spray maybe we don't go up to
them and start pushing them around hey
that's that's a part of that that Duty
it goes on the duty of belief to the
learning if all things being considered
equal if we go to somebody who we think
is actually an expert on something say a
biologist and we want to ask them about
cell division and they tell us here's
how it works
we shouldn't say uh I'll get my own
facts about that alternative facts we
should say no that they actually know
what they're talking about now does that
mean that we have to give that same
thing to the strong if the person who
has arms and authority comes up to us
and says two plus two equals five
you're perfectly in your rights to say
no you're not a mathematician and really
you're not even if you were you wouldn't
be much of one if you're thinking that's
the case we don't have to give the same
sort of things to everybody so there's
an importance of recognizing genuine and
legitimate differences
it's tyrannical to expect that simply
because you're good-looking that
therefore you should be given a seat at
the table and discussing some
intellectual matter it's wrong it's
tyrannical to think that because you're
intelligent and have studied philosophy
that therefore the people who make the
rules and who carry out public policy
ought to bring you in and listen to you
and we could go on and on and on looking
at the the second one this desire of
universal domination he talks about
different assemblies different groups of
people he says we have again the strong
the fair the sensible and he says each
person rules within their domain it's
translated here is at home right and he
says she swap within their legitimate
area of expertise or their legitimate
area of value of providing something to
the rest and not in other places the
problem comes about when they want to
get involved in the other places and you
know tell everybody else how it's going
to be so what happens then he says
sometimes they meet the strong the
good-looking
foolishly fight as to who shall be
master for their masteries of different
kinds the value that they have to
contribute is of different kinds now he
goes on and he says they don't even
understand each other and the fault
is the desire to rule everywhere the the
to dominate everybody and everything
this is Pascal thinks something that is
part of our general human nature so we
all have to be on the alert against this
and guard ourselves from falling into
this notice that the good things about
ourselves are precisely what can lead us
to become tyrannical in relation to
others so he says nothing can actually
make this work
not even might not even power which is
no use in the kingdom of the wise and is
only mistress of external actions you
can say well you know I have power so I
will make the learn and follow me or
I'll cut off their government funding or
I'll throw them in prison or I will and
you know on and on and on with
tyrannical actions to take against them
but that even if you kill all of them
even if you silence them and burn their
books you're still going to be an
ignoramus in relation to the wise you
still won't know anything by comparison
to those who actually have studied and
you know and we can go on and on and on
with this you can study as much as you
like that is not going to make you a
more attractive person you can be as
attractive as you like you can go
through cosmetic surgery you can bulk up
or slim down or whatever it is that you
think produces the aesthetically
pleasing human being and that is not
going to get you any power or make you
any smarter
he simply don't work that way so he goes
on and he says these expressions are
false
and tyrannical I am fair therefore I
must be feared
I am strong therefore I must be loved
and we could go on and on I am rich
therefore I should be accepted among the
company of scholars I helped you across
the street so therefore I have a right
to your phone number we could go on and
on and on with example after example and
the key element in all of them is going
beyond the legitimate scope of whatever
values you have Paschal also goes a
little bit further in discussing this
you might say well that's great for
those who actually are smart or rich or
good-looking or strong or pious or any
of these sorts of things but what if I'm
an average Joe or Josephine and I don't
really have that much to bring to the
table and offer Paschal in fact
discusses that - he says it's also false
and tyrannical to say he is not strong
therefore I will not esteem him he is
not able therefore I will not fear him
so there are some things that we ought
to give to other people even if a
relative for example is kind of a bitter
pill to swallow from time to time we
that doesn't mean that we don't actually
owe them some degree of affection and
interaction there could be certain lines
if they're very abusive then we we cut
them off we could go on and on with this
with everybody who were in some sort of
relation with we can behave towards them
in ways that are tyrannical or we can
behave towards them in ways that are at
least closer to justice kindness and
recognizing the legitimate differences
that we have and the different things
that we all bring to the table the
tyrant is somebody who demands that
everything not only be their way but
that all the values come
delayed around the value that they think
is the most central
you